I hear any lip in the comment section
you're all looking for a right smacked
bottom so I kind of want to revisit
twice upon a time a little bit and one
specific aspect of it in particular and
that is the depiction of the first
doctor as played by David Bradley now I
really only talked about him in a
positive context when I did my actual
review up twice upon the time because I
think he plays the part very well I
think he exudes a lot of the same energy
that William Hartnell brought to the
part he obviously looks the part really
well he's got the delivery down and I
usually didn't even mention this I I
loved his moment with Bill saying why he
left Gallifrey in the first place I love
all of that however this has become a
bit of a contentious point specifically
with people who know the first doctor
frankly a little better than I do or
much better than I do in some cases
really taking issue not necessarily with
his performance but with the way the
character is written specifically in
regards to the way he treats bill and
basically the misogynistic aspects of
the character so again keep in mind I am
not even though I'm starting to catch up
on classic Doctor Who I am NOT yes
steeped in this stuff has a lot of other
fans are and I think that's probably
part of the reason that yeah I noticed
it but it didn't it didn't register to
the degree with me that it did I think
with fans who know classic and know
first Doctor stuff in particular better
than I do and there's kind of been a bit
of backlash and I've seen some of this
in my own comment section where people
sort of claiming that like the doctor
was never anything like this William
Hartnell did not play the doctor this
way this is a complete disrespect of the
first doctor this was atrocious how dare
Moffat do this whereas for me and I
think honestly probably most knew who
fans we just didn't notice it at all or
or made some degree of assumption of
well chose made in the sixties that he
probably was wasn't he
so I want to dig into this a little bit
more now this is by no means
comprehensive but the first thing I do
want to address is that as I said I've
seen it come up with my comment section
now I've even seen the arguments made
elsewhere you know that the the first
doctor was not misogynistic in any way
now again I don't know William
Hartnell's whole run I only know a
handful of it here and there but I can
give you an example right from the very
first episode where I'm sorry he kind of
was during an unearthly child very first
episode ever broadcast Ian and Barbara
the two school teachers who Susan is
their student and they're trying to
think something's weird with this girl's
so they followed her to this junkyard
they've seen her go into the police box
they're trying to figure out what's
going on or they they thought they saw
her go there they they're trying to
figure out what what is going on here
they brought in to the doctor and they
start questioning him and I went back
and relooked at this scene again and
there were a couple things I noticed
when Barbara suggests that she saw Susan
go into the police box the doctor is
incredibly dismissive oh you must have
imagined it when Ian says that he wants
answers the doctor doesn't dismiss him
or try and Gaslight him instead he tries
to offer him a more logical reasoned
excuse and then not very long after that
when Barbara asks the doctor basically
the same question again the doctor not
only fails to answer her but takes Ian
by the arm leads him away from her and
talks to him instead there's a very
clear dismissive attitude towards
Barbara and kind of a presumption of
authority given by the doctor towards
Ian so now this is just the first
episode and I like is that there's not a
comprehensive list of incidences like
this but if I can find something in
episode 1
I look people who love the first doctor
there is something here that having been
said what was done in twice upon a time
is way more blatant and it's very
obviously been ratcheted up too well to
try and make a point
basically so and that I think there is
reason to be upset about that but I
think there is a little bit of a false
narrative going on right now I'm saying
it's been created out of whole cloth it
wasn't there were tendencies there I can
see them but like I said
weh-weh played much bigger in twice upon
a time so they it does look like Moffat
took something that was there but then
went with it and there's other things
that like are in a weird nebula zone cuz
like that smacked bottom line that the
doctor says to bill that's actually a
direct lift from the classic series he
said that to a woman but it was also his
granddaughter so it was said in a
paternal Disciplinary sense not in a
putting a woman in her place and so
again like it's a it's a turn of phrase
that at the time was fine but looking
back on it is kinda like I don't know
about that but then they put it into a
new context that made it much more
specifically and overtly misogynistic as
opposed to just like that was kind of
weird so again it is building off of
something that was that was present and
did exist but playing it up for more
than it was worth and as someone who
like I said this didn't hit me
right off the bat watching twice upon a
time I do have to kind of give a grant
and a certain apology to fans of the
first doctor that yeah I'm sorry I
didn't note that I genuinely am because
you I would say you have a right yeah
well not a rhyming you have a right to
feel whatever you feel that that was a
stupid choice of words but you've got
there's there's something there there is
a relevance to your objection and your
anger even at the degree to which all of
this was taken and for me even though I
still do really like that episode that
is a specific aspect that I'll be honest
it kind of becomes hard to defend
because I understand why it was done in
terms of the point that was being made
except that that specific point didn't
really feed directly into what was going
on in the episode so I'm not sure it was
worth sullying the first doctor in order
to get it across now I suppose it's
possible that it could retroactively Lee
become more relevant because I know it's
it's floating out there and I've seen it
in my comments that there's this notion
that somehow you know Bill is part of
the reason that the doctor regenerated
to a woman or there's even the notion
that the doctor seeing himself sort of
that backwards thinking has you know it
made a deliberate choice to become a
woman instead but but none of that is
explicit in twice upon a time itself so
limiting it to the episode yes this
legitimately becomes a problem but even
expanding beyond the episode itself it
also becomes a bit of a problem because
we've not we now know I mean we've known
for a while that time loads can change
genders with regeneration and the doctor
now has as well and more to the point
the doctor himself talking it up like
yeah we don't care about gender you know
as a society Time Lords are kind of
above that which aren't that fine I buy
that unfortunately the first doctors
depiction and twice a pot and the time
doesn't quite square with that because I
mean granted he's younger but also 2,000
years of nonlinear time at that I can't
imagine that Time Lord society was that
backwards you know at the time that the
doctor would have been that much anger
especially first as a variety that has
theoretically been around for as long as
the time loads have 2,000 years isn't
even that long to them as far as these
things go so how do we have that make
sense because like I said there is a
certain degree of it in
classic ooh but to look at the stuff
that I was talking about specifically
you you could buy and I'm not sure if I
buy this explanation and I'll explain
why in a minute but for purposes of
headcanon and if nothing else you could
make the argument that the doctor has
this presumption of authority towards
Ian and this dismissiveness of Barbara
because he's trying to blend in and
because that is how human society is at
that specific point in time in which he
is there and he's simply trying to go
with the flow or something like that I
personally know if I buy it because in
that very first episode the doctor is
really kind of just dismissive of human
civilization as a whole he seems annoyed
with Susan that they're even there in
the first place so I that that doesn't
quite roll with me with somebody who
would have done enough research to do
that degree of blending in he just seems
to want to hole up in his TARDIS and
just be left alone but you know there's
wiggle room there headcanon wise I
actually think that that's an argument
in a possibility that makes slightly
more sense with the doctor at the point
that we see him in toys upon a time
because at that point he would have been
traveling with humans from what was at
that point modern era earth for so long
he may very well have adopted some of
their customs even if it's not a
deep-rooted belief in himself that may
have started to become his default just
out of habit because that's who he's
interacting with the most much in the
same way that I feel at least accounts
for why the Tenth Doctor acts as human
as he does more so than I think any
other doctor because it makes sense he
believes Gallifrey to be gone earth is
kind of his adoptive home he goes made
him a little bit he acts more human the
more that he's around them and
especially in the case of the Tenth
Doctor the more that he's going to cling
to them because his own home is gone so
you know springboarding off that which
was something I kind of always already
believed I could buy that the doctor at
the time we see him in twice upon a time
with David Bradley play
him is has possibly just been around
humans enough from that time era that
he's kind of absorbed into the absorb
that into his just the way he begins to
interact with humans and is just
starting to default to that to a certain
extent now even if I go to that to that
place to sort of make it kind of work in
my head is it still overplayed yeah so
this is me basically conceding as
something of a corrective that yeah
twice upon a time ultimately is somewhat
damaging to the image and the reputation
of the first doctor to a degree that is
somewhat unwarranted again I want to
stress not based in nothing not invented
whole cloth but certainly pushed harder
to make a point that at least as the
episode itself is concerned I'm not sure
as a point that it really needed to make
and the one thing I did say at the time
even though I didn't single out how it
may or may not have been sullying the
reputation of the first doctor I did
point out that they kept making that
joke a lot and it was kind of not even
funny but I was kind of fine with it the
first time and then they kept making
that joke like that whole aspect was
overdone in the first place and having
looked into it a bit more to understand
the anger that I saw from some first
doctor fans yeah you know what yeah I
think you've got a legitimate grievance
and I want I want to apologize for not
giving that it's due when I did my
actual review of the episode so those
are my thoughts on the depiction of the
first doctor in twice upon a time what
are your thoughts about it whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it do up stuff like
subscribe I'm on Twitter I got an email
a podcast I got a patreon links for all
that stuff is down below so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]